[Laughter]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by tessa thompson
she's an actress whose resume runs the
gamut from critically acclaimed indies
to box office shattering blockbusters
including westworld creed thor and many
others and on the topic you can catch
your nervous valkyrie in the latest
marvel release thor love and thunder
coming to theaters july 8th tessa
thompson welcome to the show hey thanks
so much for having me this is so cool
what's going through your head as we
prepare to dig in here
i'm just wondering if i made the right
choices this morning like i didn't eat
that seems like a good thing to do but
then also should i have lined my stomach
you know i'm just i'm thinking around if
i if i'm prepared
well there's no looking back now are you
ready to get started
[Music]
really nice
i might like a little more have at it i
got a smell
what's happening here
okay peppery note yeah it's a garlic hit
mm-hmm a lot to play with in there a lot
to play with balanced on the tongue
there we go
[Laughter]
i didn't eat so
now we're lining the stomach you know
[Music]
so the thing that makes the thor
franchise my favorite in the mcu is it's
particularly irreverent and comedic tone
especially when you compare it to other
superhero movies what would you say
makes taika ytt's approach as director
unique in the genre i've heard you gush
about his childlike sensibilities i
think that's a big part of it also when
we made ragnarok the whole idea was to
basically destroy
every thor movie that had come before
not in terms of success just to like
bash all of the tropes the tone and make
something that's entirely different
this next installment has been
interesting because it's trying to sort
of recapture the magic but i think it's
being able to hold a lot of different
tonal pockets all at once can a film be
funny and silly and irreverent but also
can it be heartfelt can it be earnest
and can those things careen into each
other in a way that feels organic but i
sort of think that that's the way that
life is so it makes sense plus we play a
lot of music i think that helps
[Music]
mello
that's how we start you off
lull you into a false sense of security
terrifying
but it's it's it's jumping on the tongue
yeah little dancing right here yeah like
tat like tap dancing like without tap
shoes on you know what i mean like it's
just a light little flutter of a light
rain on a tin roof exactly there we go
one you can hardly hear you're like is
that
oh yeah that's it
so i often hear actors liking the marvel
films to greek mythology or shakespeare
is there anything that you learned while
performing at the los angeles women's
shakespeare company that helped inform
your approach to valkyrie oh that's so
interesting yeah something we talked
about because you know we're always
gender swapping so many of the women in
that company would play
men and there was this idea that men
just are more kind of upright that we
that men aren't inclined to like break
their lines and for some reason that we
associate that with power
so if i'm here talking to you in a scene
and i'm doing a lot of this or
this it's a way of signaling it
shouldn't be but a way of signaling that
i don't have as much power and so i
think in taking on valkyrie this
character that wants to feel really
powerful not masculine necessarily but i
thought a lot about that in terms of
body position and then also just getting
buff helped
and then to dust off a question from the
david harbor episode what do you think
is the best on-ramp to shakespeare for
those of us who've swearing off the work
since reading macbeth in 10th grade
i mean i got really into shakespeare but
it was not it took me a while because i
was like what is this doesn't make sense
i think the truth is the first time i
saw it perform really well it was
crystal
clear um what cliff's notes is
shakespeare for dummies
get me back on the train
[Music]
oaxacan
okay i'm into this i like mezcal
kind of a step up oh really
not to lead the witness
mm-hmm you know how the last ones take a
minute this one is like
lets you know right away it's pepper
forward
this might be my favorite so far here we
go it's dancing if the last one was
dancing in the back of the tongue this
one
on the front and maybe even wearing
shoes this time it might be wearing
shoes not stilettos it's still like
comfy but
it's reminding you it exists there we go
can i ask you a question whatever you
want
the first sip of water is that like a
deduction in terms of
no no whatever we want it to be like the
most comfortable least comfortable
interview you know what i mean so if you
need a water i'm gonna make up a milk
and you've got like some lifelines and
some unique lifelines i have bread i i
have i got rice i'm taking care there we
go totally you're in good hands over
here
so last year you launched a production
company viva mod something that i've
always been curious about are there
certain kinds of stories that are harder
to adapt than others yeah like all the
ones i want to adapt
no but also i really love books i love
reading books and so there's a lot of
novels that we're trying to adapt and
it's ambitious you know because they're
sprawling and also there are things that
you can do on the page in terms of
articulating ideas and thoughts of the
character and how do you communicate
that in film
language it takes some real
consideration
[Music]
i'm doing great
okay
[Music]
dancing on a little bit
i love this one it's really smooth
throughout
it's
if i dare say so myself a little
it's face it's kinky oh i like that it's
feisty
there you go you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah you're a tagline yeah i'm
gonna switch up the tagline you know no
no no maybe the better word is is it
zesty it's got some zest okay it's zesty
i'd say it's got some zest but i like
kinky we're gonna go with pinky okay
it's binding
so it's rare for us to interview a
hollywood star who's actually from la
but we're happy to put you in the
pantheon alongside elizabeth olsen and
kristen stewart elizabeth olsen by the
way is my favorite hot ones interview of
all time you know what i saw in new york
city in new york city
the amount i i did that for a long time
even when i was not in new york city
i was in a new york city state of mind
um
[Music]
well
i'm in new york city
that interview meant a lot to me
forwards to backwards that's why i'm
wearing a blazer and she was wearing a
blazer so that's a good easter egg i
love that i love that
do you think that there's something
about being from the heart of the
entertainment industry that affects the
way that you view it or is it reductive
to think that actors from la have a
certain sensibility
no i don't think it's reductive i think
that's probably true it also depends on
how you come in
to the industry even especially living
in los angeles for me
hollywood was not
so much um an institution because i
didn't know anybody at it
like where all the stars are marilyn
monroe's hands and feet like that was
basically my front yard
in the same way that i
saw this romance around people would
come to la on this pilgrimage for a
dream i was like well i want to go on a
pilgrimage for a dream i just don't know
i just don't know where and then once i
realized that that acting is what i
wanted to do and storytelling is what i
wanted to do
i was like well
here i am i guess
ooh reaper okay
you know reaper
[Music]
climbing it's stagey
yeah right it comes in waves yeah a
little bit yeah it's like
right and then you think you're good and
then and then it's like
it hasn't hit me with the full
a little bit there
as if it hurt me
i think they do sometimes you know you
think they do
but this is nice it's settling on my
tongue
nicely here we go back part of it fully
soaked fully marinated and while you sit
in that marinade tessa thompson we have
a recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context no and
for the first time in years after this
long hiatus
the laptop is back camera got built can
you still do it there we go
he's still got it so we'll show you the
picture you just tell us the bigger
story
as a self-described people watcher who
also studied cultural anthropology
what's your take on comic
comic-con's cool and i got to do it
really anthropologically because i stole
a stormtrooper uniform and i walked the
floor the whole time people were like
you can't walk the floor a you don't
have time and also it would be just too
chaotic and so i just borrowed one of
these things and took to the floor
and it was
so fun
like i i wish i could do that just for a
day and and also i'd love to be able to
like plan
uh a real
costume and a real look but really spend
comic-con
that way
and also to be there with someone like
chris hemsworth i mean you see the face
i'm making in there i'm like
people are really into him
all right that concludes explain that
graham
bill got it
looking good bud thank you for working
out all right you ready to move on here
to the back half collard and ghost here
in the sixth spot mm-hmm
[Music]
okay
a little bit of a different color
[Music]
oh it's a lot of saliva happening in my
mouth
it's it's getting watery in there
[Laughter]
so you've worked closely with director
ryan coogler and have interesting
thoughts about how to take something
with the size and scale of a hollywood
blockbuster but still give it a real
point of view
what have you learned by working with
each other about navigating the
intersection of art and commerce oh
that's such a good question i think it's
like amazing to have your own
autonomy to get to do whatever you
want but it's also incredible to be able
to make something that you know a lot of
people are going to be able to see and
especially on a global scale
and that's like that's such a rare gift
that not that many filmmakers make and
particularly filmmakers that come so
steeped in the independent world you get
so
so
much access and sometimes i think there
is this thing of like mo money more
problems you know as soon as you have
money there are people like really
telling you how to spend it but
i've never seen someone deal with that
more gracefully than ryan i also think
so much you make these things and you
put them out into the world and they're
not yours anymore anyways you know
which is the
beautiful and terrifying thing about
them
all right you are doing so good okay
you're approaching this home stretch
here
this next one is tirfen's curse here in
the seven spot
okay from hollowgee
[Music]
it's building
one of those yeah
there's a little bit of that
it's a slight watering of the eyes but
it's not
it's not a bad that's not a bad thing
and then this is where i'll just say be
careful you know because don't touch the
eye don't touch the eyes you know your
instinct don't want you'll want to
but avoid at all costs how often do
people drool
oh every episode okay cool go ahead and
let it fly okay not now i might wait
until i get to 9.
as a musician yourself how would you
distill the experience of working
alongside composer ludwig gorensen to
make original music for creed like i
imagine that's a unique experience to
create music in the context of a film
from the perspective of your character
yeah that was so wild too because we we
basically locked ourselves in a studio
for two weeks and then he we'd have
friends of
him come over and
write with us
um like donald glover and sam du and
moses sumnee and all these incredible
artists and
you know i've dabbled in music but
i'm not like them they can like
do anything they could eat like
two cutting boards of these hot wings
you know and then like sit down and and
sing
it also felt like preparation for the
role it was kind of like a fake until
you make it i don't know you know what i
mean uh this one's getting to me all
right tessa are you ready to move on
here to the next wing
it brings me no joy to say this but this
is the bomb beyond insanity
[Music]
[Music]
the jump between this and that is
exponential
[Laughter]
does this work
you told me oh it makes it worse
it rubs it no it makes it worse
yeah it's like taking a cut and rubbing
it on the carpet okay okay let me see
what happens yeah
[Music]
yep
that's all you it is a good thing to do
yeah just anything you can do to survive
and i'll gas pedal adhere to the finish
line
do you have a lasting memory from being
a bar mitzvah dancer that seems like
such an interesting job you know getting
people from age 13 to 95 to rally to the
dance floor that seems like a unique
challenge for even the most seasoned
entertainer
what was your question
bar mitzvah dancer um did you have a
lasting memory or how would you distill
the experience
it was a lot of spandex
a lot of
wrangling grannies
and um
a lot of horrors
what not
hora
you know
they put you in the chair and hoist you
up i'm fully crying yeah yeah it's okay
because um
really dancing at bar mitzvahs brings up
memories
for me um
i think really
the experience of
being there
on such a pivotal time in um
a family's lives
being able to
support that be a part of it
get everybody moving and dancing
it kept the lights on
this is
fully clearing my sinuses yeah
a transcendent experience something that
you know you walk through
get to the other side and you're a
changed person at the end of it
[Music]
when does the mouth when does it when
does it go away
it's a nightmare a show i have to
apologize for
i love it man it makes me feel alive
[Music]
the dingo psycho sauce from australia
i know you recently spent some time in
australia yeah
this is a taste of
australia let me eat this dingo baby
ready i'm ready
[Music]
um this one sucks but i think after the
last one
that was done
there's something about that's just a
little bit easier oh
[Music]
yeah it's not as bad
[Music]
right all downhill from here all
downhill from here tessa
as a thrift store vet do you have a
vintage secondhand clothing hack that
you can share with the people we've had
past hot ones guests extol the virtues
of shape overall else when it comes to
vintage tees
yeah shape is good but you know i have a
really weird thing which is
i feel like and this is gonna sound
really crazy
i get a hit i got a feeling
what i need when there's a vintage thing
somewhere for me
oh like a
sixth sense yeah
and i'm like i gotta go to this place
today
i feel that sometimes i don't know if
it's just that i'm like in the need for
retail therapy or something but
that's my advice is to try to channel
the vintage gods for when you might need
to get to a place to look for some
things
all right tessa thompson hmm
reaching for it she knows
[Music]
i'm gonna i made it this far
i saw that coming
[Music]
okay
cheers tessa
cheers cheers
[Music]
yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
that one will make you spin in your bar
chair as queen latifah would say
that's a spicy meatball
but the good thing tessa thompson mm-hmm
like valkyrie battling the god butcher
we've taken on the wings of death lived
to tell the tale and just one blind spot
in our interview and that's tessa
thompson and goats yeah you've talked
about similarities that you have with
goats but what i'm interested here on
wing 10 is your personal goats so with
your brain on fire and mouth ablaze i'll
hit you with some categories you just
give me the tessa thompson greatest of
all time okay great
goat craft service snack
spicy hot cheez-its there we go
goat movie adapted from a book
talented mr ripley
goat hot sauce
some pirate hot sauce amazingness
pirate's lantern maybe
we've actually had that on the show
before
pirates lantern put it on the throne
because tessa thompson said so and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
um
there's so many things to
enjoy this week i'm gonna go to london
and i'm and i'm gonna eat curry because
it's the national dish there it's the
best place to
eat curry
uh we our movie is gonna
i think we're gonna it's gonna come out
and people are gonna see it and um i'm
hoping with all this talk of goats that
i i have some time to spend with goats
in some
secret situations i i don't mean that in
like a
weird way i just mean that i want to
have more access i feel like this might
give me more
access to goats
than i've had before
[Music]
i did it right you crushed it
i have been asked ever since my family
found out i was coming on the show and
friends of mine i get asked constantly
when it's happening
everyone is so excited and also it very
much was a moment of like oh you've made
it like you're going to the hot ones
like
oh marble like whatever you're big time
no really and truly like they were
shocking
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's video
the season 18 sauces they're here and
you know what that means dom box me
so is the big box the season 18 hot ones
box is now available at heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands
and all of the season 18 sauces
delivered straight to your door in one
convenient box don't forget to be
careful around the eyes